Well, welcome everybody,
great to see you.
We are lucky enough today
to have David Mohr from
Northwestern University here
joining us today to talk about
his great work that he's been
doing on the crossroads between
behaviour change, technology,
and serious mental health.
David is one of the pioneers
using mobile technology,
sensing platforms, and
suites of applications.
And really studying their
efficacy with real users who
have real problems over time.
Weaves this technology
into their everyday lives,
which is what I really
appreciate about it.
And I'm gonna stop there and
let him tell you about it.
I forgot to say that he's also
in the School of Medicine at
Northwestern and he's the
director of CBIT, which stands
for the Center for Behavioral
Intervention Technologies which
is very well known.
So welcome, David.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thanks very, very much.
It's really a pleasure to be
here to spend some time with
Mary and
to get to know some of you.
So thank you for
inviting me out.
First, I'm a clinical
psychologist by training.
And I've collaborated with
people in HCI and computer
science and engineering enough
to get myself into trouble.
But that's not the area that
I know that much about.
So most of
this is gonna be from the
perspective of a psychologist.
So I'll start off
with just a few
slides to kind of set the frame
work in terms of psychology.
The I'm gonna talk
a little bit about
kind of a new direction that we
have, Mary already eluded to
that we call Intelicare,
a platform of applications and
then talk a little
bit about sensing.
So, I have to mention this,
there's disclosures.
So I've had consulting fees
from Otsuka and Optum.
And then I have an ownership
interest in Actualize Health,
which is trying to commercialize
some of the things we're
talking about.
So, mental health, most of
what I'm gonna focus on is
common mental health problems
like depressions and anxiety.
But mental health
problems are common.
So around 20 to 25% of Americans
will have a mental health
problem in any given year.
And the common ones
like mood disorders and
anxiety disorders you can see
that the prevalence rates there.
Our workforce is inadequate.
So only around 20% of
Americans receive what's
called minimally adequate care.
And believe me when you look
at what minimally adequate is,
it is far more minimal
than adequate.
And if we have about
half the number of mental
health professionals that we
would need to treat people,
and we're never gonna
have enough people.
And even if we had them,
they wouldn't necessarily
be where the patient are.
So 90 million Americans live in
federal designated mental
profession shortage areas,
higher than any other
medical specialty.
So this is the argument for
digital mental health.
When we think about treating
people with mental health
problems, behaviorally or
with psychological treatments,
usually there's some kind of,
we've tended to use
theories that were developed for
psychotherapy.
And this is one of
the most common ones,
there are a lot of them.
And so this theory,
cognitive behavioral theory,
starts from the premise that
when people are experiencing
emotional disorders,
we can't reach inside, like with
a pharmaceutical, reach inside
and change that feeling.
But we can leverage the fact
that our thoughts, and
our behaviors, and our feelings
are all affected, right?
So if I came in here and I were
thinking these people, man,
they're really smart.
They're gonna judge
me really harshly.
I better do a good job.
I would be nervous.
It would affect my thoughts.
It would make me feel nervous.
I might be jittery in
my behaviors, right?
But if I come in and think, well
you know they might have some
disagreements with what I say.
And we could get into some
interesting discussions.
My whole approach, my thoughts,
my feelings will be different,
right?
So we usually start
with a theory.
I'm not sure if
that's a good idea,
that's what we've done
up until now, but
I just wanna put that out there.
The other thing I wanna
talk about is some features
of treatment for mental health
problems that we should keep
in mind when we're thinking
about treating mental health.
So one is, they're slow.
It's not like you take
a pill and you get better.
Psychotherapy or pharmacotherapy
takes at least four
weeks even to have
the first impact.
And psychotherapies often
take 8 to 20 weeks.
Pharmacotherapy to get a full
response usually takes
several months and
then people have to be on it.
So when we think about digital
mental health, we're not talking
about people using an app for
a couple of days.
This is something that needs
to be sustained over time.
It's challenging and it's hard.
When people are depressed,
they don't have any
motivation to do anything.
They feel like nothing
is gonna help.
For people with anxiety,
they become fearful and
they think, this is not gonna
work, this is not gonna work.
And so
its hard to keep people on task.
And so if you think about
people using an app over time,
these are gonna be really
challenging to achieve that.
And so what we end up with
in psychotherapies or
in treatments generally is we
have specific factors like
teaching people to monitor their
thoughts, or teaching people to
change their behaviors, those
are kinda the specific skills.
And then we have what we call
nonspecific factors, like
empathy, warmth, instillation
of hope that are common
to all treatments that try to
keep people engaged, okay?
So this is just sort of
features to keep in mind
from psychotherapy that
might be applicable.
So just a brief history
of digital mental health.
People started playing with
this about 20 years ago as
the Internet became ubiquitous,
and people developed websites.
The idea was to take
psychotherapy and
deliver it through a new medium.
And so
they took some of the components
like in psychotherapy.
Therapists teach
patients things, right?
Patients come in,
they don't know some things,
the therapist teach them things.
And so some of the websites,
this is an old website
that we've taken down.
But just didactics via video and
via text.
A lot of forms of
psychotherapy have homework,
sort of work sheets.
This is a common one for CBT.
And so those get instantiated
in the websites.
And then what happened was we
started to build these things
and nobody would use them.
So what we did was we put
coaches in to try to get people
to stay on board.
And so
there were dashboards that kinda
helped coaches understand what
the patients were doing to help
them keep people on board.
Okay, so this is kind of
the standard mental health
digital mental health.
And there are some people doing
more interesting things, but
if you look at the commercial
world this is pretty much where
we still are.
If you think about
Marshal McClellan said that
in any new medium,
the first instance of that new
medium is imitating the old one.
And that's what we've done here
is we've imitated the old medium
of face to face hypotherapy,
at least we've tried to.
And that's taken us a long way.
There have been more than
a hundred randomized controlled
trials now.
And they've pretty consistently
shown that if you just offer it
without any kind of support,
you get a minimal effect.
It's not very big.
People tend not to use it.
They tend not to stay engaged.
But if you add in a coach,
you get effect sizes that start
to look like psychotherapy.
And they start to look
like pharmacotherapy.
So you can get some pretty
robust effect sizes.
And your coaches don't
need to be therapists.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah,
human coaches right now.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Right,
people have done with email,
messaging,
phone calls, sometimes more
times, sometimes less.
So there's a lot variability in
terms of what that coaching is
and we'll get there, but I think
one of the problem is we haven't
really defined what that is.
But this then,
we have a big research database.
And then when you look
at implementation,
as we've started talking
to Kaiser Permanente and
large care systems around
the United States and
indeed around the world we see,
I have not seen yet one single
successful implementation
inside a care center yet.
They may be our there but
I haven't seen it, and
I've seen a lot of failures.
And so we have a huge research
to practice gap here,
which is not uncommon
in medicine.
But I think that this
means that there's some
fundamental problems in
how we've approached this.
And there are kind
of a lot of them and
we outlined some of them
in this paper here.
I'm gonna talk about
two of them here.
One is I think the design
has been atrocious, and
I'll talk about
that in a moment.
And then the other is we've
ignored the human side, and
I'm not talking about here.
I'm not talking about putting
apps up on the app store.
That's perfectly useful.
We've had self-help books for
decades in the stores, and
people can get those.
But I'm talking about
designing systems or
tools that can be embedded
in our healthcare system
which is where I think we're
gonna actually make an impact.
So we've ignored the systems and
the human side of it.
So the design problems, Beating
the Blues is one of the oldest,
and still I think it's still
commercially available.
And it's basically a 50-minute
session, psychoeducational
sessions, that teach CBT
skills via text and video.
It's not badly designed,
but when you see
the implementations,
people don't use it.
When people are depressed,
they don't wanna go home and
watch a video,
50-minute video every week.
You can't get people to do it.
That, I think, is the problem.
And there are others that maybe
this is an extreme example, but
a lot of them have this
kind of flavor to it.
So we've developed products
that people don't use.
And then I think what
we do is we go out and
we recruit 400 people
from the Internet.
And we find the 400 people who
are willing to use the crap that
we've built,
excuse my French, and
then we call that the evidence.
So it's not surprising
that we can't get
the stuff to work
in the real world.
The development's been top down.
It's been people like me
deciding what patients
need to have.
And then we get that to them,
and
then we try to push them to
do what we think they should.
And it hasn't fit into
the fabric of people's lives.
So one of the challenges that
we've been thinking about
in terms of starting to deliver
tools digitally to people is in
mental health, we have lots and
lots of behavioral strategies.
So when a person has depression,
you don't treat depression.
You don't say,
we're gonna fix your depression.
Ultimately, what we're talking
about is little components of
treatment, right?
So we have behavioral
activation.
So we try to get
people to out and
do more positive stuff, right?
We have cognitive restructuring
to try to help people recognize
negative thoughts.
So we have goal setting,
problem solving,
lots of behavioral strategies.
And some work for some people,
others work for other people.
Some people prefer some.
So how do you structure that?
And then at the same time,
increasingly, we have
lots of different features
in the technology, right?
So just for apps, you've
got text, you've got video,
you've got audio,
you've got messaging.
You can do tracking,
you can do logging, feedback.
There's all kinds of different
ways that people interact.
Some people like logging things.
Some people hate logging things.
So you can see here that if
we're gonna design something
that's gonna help the vast
majority of people, you're gonna
be filling in a grid here
that's gonna be enormous.
And how do you design a system
that is gonna meet people
with the interaction styles
that they prefer, and
the kind of
behavioral strategies?
And so what we've
started to do is to say,
we can't develop an app for
this.
[LAUGH] What we can do,
the way that people use apps or
tools right now is
the little component parts.
You don't use an app to
manage your entire life.
You use an app to
find a restaurant,
you use a map to map it there.
You use an app to manage
your plane flight.
You have little apps that
do little things, right?
And so what we've done is
created a suite of apps,
kind of this is a sort of
a representation that we call in
IntelliCare, and
it's 13 or 14 apps.
And each one is just a single
behavioral strategy and
a single interaction style.
And so, the goal is to
get something that for
the most part,
can be used pretty quickly.
People can open it,
they can use it, and
then they're done with it.
And then there's one app
that we call the hub app,
that if people download that,
it organizes their interaction
with the whole suite, right?
So it's just breaking it down
into the component parts, so
they can be flexibly applied
to people as needed.
Everybody with me?
Okay, so
this is just an example.
So Day to Day,
I'll give you some examples.
These are all up on Google Play,
and
I think the first three of
four of them are up on iOS.
So Day to Day is more didactic,
kind of like those old ones.
So it'll give a brief sort of
didactic explanation each week,
and then give reminders, sort of
messages every day to kinda keep
people reminded of that
sort of lesson, right?
So this is kind of traditional.
This is sort of a traditional
Thought Challenger thing.
So you go in, you can can
identify a negative thought, and
then find a way of
challenging it.
But then there are others like
Daily Feats is really pretty
simple.
You get in, you peg your
level of depression.
If you're really depressed,
you start at Level 1.
And I got out of bed, I groomed
myself, I made good food
choices, or I ate something,
and I went outside.
That's it.
And you check those
off each day, four or
five times in a row, and
then you level up to Level 2,
and you get another set.
You can add some in if you want,
takes ten seconds, that's it.
This app has actually been the
most popular app, cuz it's so
simple.
And so I thought,
nobody's ever gonna use this,
when it was one of my
developers thought it up.
This one gets used more than
any of them cuz it's simple.
This one uses images
a little bit more.
So you can take a photo, add
a mantra to it, and it loads and
it reminds you of that
mantra periodically.
That's all it does.
So we've had, since the last
two years from Google Play,
we've had about 80,000 installs,
76,000 unique users.
And as of a couple of days ago,
there were 10,000 active users,
meaning that they've used one of
the apps over the last 30 days.
So it's been working
pretty well.
If we've looked at a benchmark,
one benchmark that's been used
for health apps is,
most people download an app.
And you maybe open it once and
never look at it again.
So this was a diet app, and
2.6% of people used it
more than 10 times.
So by that, around 5 to 35%
of the people that have
downloaded an IntelliCare
app have met that criteria.
So you can see here,
across all the apps on average,
they're used about 13 times
over the course of a month.
The Daily Feats, our top one
is used 27 times over 45
days on average,
Day to day, over 38 days.
And then, all the way down here,
this one is so much of a dog,
we've pulled it off.
We haven't been able to fix it.
So some of these others
here need more help.
And I should also say,
we've been iterating over these,
after we've put them up there.
We get people to give
us feedback, and
we made changes until
we ran out of money.
And now they're up
there the way they are.
So, we also Have done a trial.
This is, so
we've done two trials now,
I'll talk about the first one.
The second one, we're just
starting to analyze the data.
So this is just the first
field trial with 100 people.
And so this was starting to look
at how do you put this into
a care system with coaching?
And so we enrolled 99 people,
who had the PHQ
as a measure of depression and
the GID as a measure of anxiety.
So, these are people
with elevated levels,
levels of depression and
anxiety where physicians would
refer them for treatment.
And so this is the dashboard.
And there's, this here is the
apps, when they've been used and
launched, and if the care
manager clicks on it,
it gives them
a little information.
This is,
manages the text messaging.
This is the apps that
are installed and the apps that
are being used and then this
is their sort of history of
symptom severity, so this is
all that the coaches get.
And they had a 30 minute
phone call with people to get
started and
then over the eight weeks,
they just used text
messaging back and forth.
And so this is the reduction
in depression and
anxiety that we saw.
So it's substantial,
viewed another way, for
depression,everybody started
out blue,
so they all had significant
levels of depression.
And at the end of the eight
weeks 37% had no symptoms of
depression at all anymore.
40% had dropped
below the threshold,
there still have some
residual symptoms.
And 22% still had symptoms
that needed treatment.
So these are good findings
we were please with this.
And we've currently just
finished randomized trial and
the outcomes are looking
very similar.
So how might this work?
Why might this be working?
Well I mean at a simple level,
people are using the app.
So maybe that's helping, and
they're getting coaching so
those are the two pieces here.
So let's look at the app use.
So the average app launch
is over eight weeks
were 195 app launches.
And if you know,
if you're familiar with
kind of that's a lot.
That and typically when you-
>> Per person?
>> What?
>> Per person,
over eight weeks, yeah.
And just in those eight weeks.
And when you look at app use for
these interventions,
typically you get kind of
a hockey stick, right?
You get people,
they start off using it and
then in the first week or two
they drop off and it gets low.
Here what we see is people
are consistently using three or
four, launching
the apps three or
four times a day throughout
the entire trial.
And in fact two-thirds of
them continue to use them
after the trial ended.
And so I think the reason
that we see that,
there's, one is that the average
time it takes is a minute and
the median is 17 seconds.
So we have a bunch of apps
that are like the checklist,
they just take a few seconds
to use, they're simple.
And there are a couple
that are longer,
like there's some relaxation, so
that it takes five minutes, ten
minutes depending on the video.
But in general they
are simple to use, so
they can fit easily into
the fabric of people's lives.
The other I think is that the
idea and I hadn't thought of of
this when we designed it, but
people are getting new apps.
They use the apps for
a couple, a week or two and
then they use another one.
And so it's not like
staying with the same app,
there's novelty involved.
And so they're not
necessarily getting sick of
doing the same thing over and
over again.
So then I wanna go back and
talk about you.
So you've already
seen these data,
this is from
the public deployment.
So this is fresh data, so
it's not exactly comparable but
you can see here that for
the apps, the mean here is
27 in the, with the coaching
it was mean at 29 so it's
not exactly the same metric.
But it's sort of in the,
you can see this is in
the same ballpark, right.
So the use patterns once
somebody has it on their phone
the use pattern within any
individual app is kind of
the same which is surprising.
So the coaches aren't
necessarily getting,
once the app's on their
phone the coaches aren't
really getting them to
use it more necessarily.
But what you see up here
is that people are using
more of the apps.
The coach is really able to get
them to use more of the apps.
I think in the public deployment
two-thirds of the people only
use one app.
And one-third then start
using a number of them.
And it's mostly the people
who download the Hub app
who end up using more of them
cuz they get recommendations.
So recommendations maybe
increase app use and
this is just the data from the
first people with the Hub app on
their phone, and they get, they
end up for these different apps
they end up, if a recommendation
automatically is launched it
increases the likelihood that
they're going to use that app by
this amount, yeah?
>> So your individual apps don't
recommend any of the other apps?
Just the Hub recommends the?
>> It all goes through the hub.
And so the Hub,
thank you for asking that.
So what the Hub does is it
monitors what's on the phone and
then it will make
a recommendation,
each week it'll
recommend a new app.
Initially we just did it
randomly and we've recently put
in just a commodity recommender
engine that increases the, so
then I'll show you,
it increases slightly.
But we think that where we're
going with this is we think that
if we can start to learn how
to recommend it, we can start
to increase the helpfulness
of those recommendations.
>> Was there a reason that you
don't have each individual app
all at the end say, and
check out our other apps?
>> No, there's no good reasons
for why we did it that way.
Honestly, I think we were just
trying to figure out how to get
this out and launched.
So we didn't have we had the Hub
app do a number of things.
Once that's, once the Hub app
is on the phone, it manages
the recommendations, it then
manages all the notifications,
so it kind of everything then
goes through the Hub app.
It also, I think it's probably
need, entire need of some
redesign because it's the thing
that people complain about
the most, so it's not
the best way to do it So,
but along those lines,
when we look at these apps,
looking at app use,
they fall into clusters.
So people who use day to day or
iCOPE or MyMantra,
if they use one of those they're
more likely to use others right.
And they fall into,
I think, four of these
seem to make sense.
So, the first column there is
language or they use sort of,
seems like they're engaging
people cognitively, so
it's sort of a psychological
method of engagement.
The second one, The Purple Chill
is the relaxation app.
Slumber Time is sleep helps
people with insomnia.
So, kind of relaxation apps,
then check-it apps that rely
on checklists so that's more,
kind of, interaction style that
seems to be holding it together.
Activity Boost Me is kind
of behavioral activation so
getting people to do
more positive activities.
Move Me is getting people to
do more physical activity.
So those kinda hang together.
So these make sense, and
these are just the worst apps
that we have, and I'm not sure.
I'm not sure analytically
what's happening, but
they're our junky app.
So you can see that, I think we
can start thinking about having
a recommender engine
that can drive,
essentially be kind of a Netflix
for mental health apps, that can
start directing people to apps
that they're more likely to use.
And we're, so
we're doing this in the context
of Intellicare right now.
So we're working with
some people at Columbia,
some biostatisticians and
machine learning people
at Columbia who are doing
the analytics to try to develop
a better system for this.
But you can also imagine that
this kind of analytic system
could be used for any app.
They don't necessarily
have to be ours.
But you can start to have
a platform that can begin to
provide guidance to people for
the, I don't know how many,
hundreds of thousands of mental
health apps that are out there
on the app stores.
So that's one direction
that we're going with
the design here.
Maybe we don't really need care
managers if we can get people to
use the apps, right?
And I still think we do.
And there's two reasons.
One is, I don't think health
care settings are gonna want to
host apps as a form
of treatment.
They're in the business
of providing services.
So I think that we have to start
thinking about how we can use
digital technologies to improve
their ability to extend
services.
And then the other is
that I think we still,
in the work that we've done, we
have some biased samples, right?
We're recruiting people
who wanna come in and
be part of a study.
These aren't your
average patients.
These are people that just the
fact that they're in our study,
they've already demonstrated
that they're more motivated than
the average person.
That's pretty different than
having a care manager say,
I think you should do x,
y, or z.
That's gonna be,
that you're gonna get
a whole different level.
We know that patients,
50% of patients don't even
take the medications that
their doctors recommend them.
So we're dealing with, I think
there's still a huge role for
care management even though it
looks like we're doing well.
So, I describe
the coaching that we did.
30 to 40 minutes of call time,
20, 25 text messages.
And when we look at the text
messages, they fall into 10 or
15 different buckets
when we cluster them.
One is, opinions about the apps.
I like this, I don't like it.
Picking which app to use, making
a decision, technical problems;
sorry, responding to the coach,
sorry, I didn't get back to you.
Excuses, scheduling, etcetera.
Things are going well, yes,
no, and thank you, right?
These are pretty well
defined buckets.
When we start looking
at the coaching.
A lot of this could be
automated, I think.
I don't think care systems
at this point are ready to
turn it all over to
something that's automated.
But, and you'll see in a minute,
I think providing automation
can really help care managers.
Cuz care managers
in these systems
are not necessarily trained in
managing mental health problems.
Yeah?
>> So if those
are the general buckets,
do you get ones that are like, I
can't go on today, please help?
Meaning calls for
help type thing?
>> I think we will.
So we, in these early studies,
we screen people out with
significant suicidality.
There are people who
have some suicidality, so
they certainly Having suicidal
ideation is part of it, and
we do get some people who talk
about those who'll raise it.
We did not have any of those
hundred people say I'm gonna go
out and kill myself.
Which does happen in
some of my studies.
So then we call them up and
we usually talk with them and
access them.
>> That's interesting, I'm also
curious about just in general
>> Maybe not suicidal just I'm
having so much stress about my
job tomorrow, not suicidal but
just needing more help as far
as dealing with anxiety or
calls for help in that sense.
>> Yeah, I mean part of, so
you know part, what I haven't
presented here is kind of
the development of our care
management model and we also
didn't get that right first.
When we started out,
as we were going through and
talking to the users and
the care managers.
There was a lot of lack of
clarity of what the role
of the care manager was.
So one of the things we had to
do Is make that pretty explicit
up front that this
is not therapy.
And still people brought
up things like a death in
the family or
significant stressors.
And so, when those came
up If it was significant
enough that they could arrange
for a second call to talk with
them for a few minutes to try to
connect them with other services
that might be more
appropriate or like that.
They didn't get into, but the
care managers did not get into
helping people solve
specific problems.
They didn't go over the line and
to starting to do the
psychotherapy in The reason for
that is that we're anticipating
that the kind of people that
would manage a system like this,
care managers,
typically don't have a lot
of mental health training.
So, you're gonna need
a system that have
a defined set of goals for
those managers.
Does that kind of answer your?
>> It does.
So it sounds like you've
gotten some of those.
Are those a lot less than these?
So you wouldn't assign
a category to those type of
incoming texts?
>> I would have to go back.
So these we just
got from somebody
that did our NLP at University
of Washington yesterday, so
I put these in last night.
So I don't [LAUGH] I don't
actually know what happened to
those sort of random ones that
didn't fit in everywhere.
So, sorry.
[LAUGH] But I think that's
when we anticipate kind of how
a system like this might work.
What I anticipate is,
I don't think in a care
system right now.
They would be comfortable with
any kind of message going out to
a patient that haven't
been breaded by human.
I think that means in any
kind of care setting.
Maybe we'll get there but
I think most care environments
right now that that's
a step too far.
But I think what we can
do is give care managers,
send this message, have them
look at it and send it.
And then have the ones that
are like you're describing,
that there isn't
an automatic response.
Here's something, here
are three different levels, or
here are three different types
of responses you might give,
or contact somebody for
further assistance on this.
Essentially guiding.
In the same way that we're
trying to give patients
guidance, I think we have to
give the care managers guidance.
On of the things we did in
August is I think is what Kale's
getting at is right off the bat
they have to give us a rating
on how suicidal they feel.
And if it goes over a certain
number we have the trigger.
We know exactly what the
response should be, call 9111.
>> Yeah, and you're dealing
with a population there that is
really very suicidal.
>> Yeah, so we have to be,
we're always super concerned.
>> Dealing with suicidality in
the context of primary care,
has been that,
each organization we have to
negotiate that differently.
Because they, obviously when you
go into primary care sort of
medical settings,
nobody wants their patients
to commit suicide.
But physicians want,
they don't have time.
What they need is,
this is what you need to do.
Here's a yes/no.
This person is suicidal,
you need to refer them,
you need to get them help.
This person is not.
And it's really difficult in
these systems to get that level
of Clarity.
So we end up for
example, when we were
working with Northwestern,
one of the outpatient
clinics in Northwestern.
We didn't assess it,
they did not want us
to assess suicidality.
They were worried
about liability.
So we screen them out, we assess
it right at the beginning and
we just screen people out who
had high levels of suicidality.
Other places, they do
want that information and
they have somebody tasked with
who can do that outreach.
So it's really, I mean again,
this is where, I think a one
size fits all, is not going
to work in our care system.
And when you see
one care system,
you've seen one care system.
And there's a lot that doesn't
translate to other care systems.
So I think these kinds of
tools are gonna have to be
adaptable to the needs of
the individual systems.
So, what we've done, and
speaking of that, what we
started doing is thinking,
realizing what we have to do.
If we're starting to think about
designing tools to go into
a care system, we have to design
for the patients, obviously.
We have to design for
whoever's gonna manage it, but
we also have to design and
understand the care system.
So we've started, we've just
now starting to work with three
different care systems.
One is Northwestern Medicine
Physician Partners,
which is an arm of
Northwestern Medicine that is
building out its
value-based care.
So they take, essentially, Blue
Cross, Blue Shield contracts.
They don't do fee-for-service.
And they're buying up practices
from Lake Michigan out to
the Mississippi River.
So they're sort of in this
expanding their footprint.
And they need to be able to
manage mental health problems.
It's a huge problem for them,
because they don't
have capacity.
And if you get out of
the greater Chicago area,
there aren't any providers.
And we've been talking to Rush,
which manages a lot of low
income clinics around Chicago.
And then we're talking with
University of Arkansas,
their medical care system,
which manages a large
rural population.
So, we started doing some
initial design work with,
you know?
Yeah, so we're working with.
It's kind of leading
up a lot of that.
And so,
I'll just give you a flavor, so
we started with
Northwestern Medicine.
And we did a lot of interviews
with people in primary care
clinics, and quickly realized
it was never gonna fly.
There was no way that
we were gonna put
this into a primary care clinic.
Because there's no bandwidth,
nobody has time,
they don't have the expertise.
So, that's where
the patients are,
but there's no staff
who can manage it.
And what we realized is that
this organization, a lot
of organizations are developing
these sort of centralized care
systems in
Northwestern Medicine is.
So it's a centralized
care management system,
where they're getting,
when physicians make referrals,
they're making sure that
patients get there.
So they'll call them up,
they'll work with them.
When they have problem patients,
they'll stay engaged with them
to try to make sure they get
the care that they need.
So these are people that are
delivering their care remotely.
And they're often dealing
patients that are kind of
difficult, or
that have problems.
So, we realized that's
probably the place.
So we've started, we've done
a first round of detailed
First round of interviews
with these care managers.
And we found a number of
barriers that have problems.
So, they don't see their role
as managing mental health,
necessarily.
They manage medical problems and
lifestyle problems, obesity,
and so on.
But they haven't seen mental
health as part of what they do.
Honestly, they don't really
know what their role is,
cuz they're developing it, and
it's kind of a chaotic system.
But they also most of them have
no training in mental health.
But on the plus side, more than
half of their patients when we
go into the medical records.
More than half of their patients
have significant
levels of depression.
So this is a population
where that's a huge problem.
And they recognized that the
depression interferes with their
ability to get
other things done.
So if they have diabetes,
they know that the people that
are depressed have a harder
time managing their diabetes.
So they recognize that
there's a problem.
There's a lot of barriers
to mental health referral.
So, either long waits, or
just lack of availability.
And they actually see
this type of system as
potentially beneficial.
So, rather than going into
a primary care where we have to
find somebody and tell them to
do something in addition to what
they're already doing.
Here we could potentially
develop a system that can make
their jobs easier.
And if we can develop a system
that makes somebody's job
easier, it is much more
likely to be implemented
in a sustainable manner.
So, so far in this setting,
they're very enthusiastic,
and we're starting to do
the same work with Rush and
with the University of
Arkansas Medical Center.
So that's kind of, I think,
yeah, okay, so okay.
So briefly, so I think what
we're looking at here is
the primary care is still, the
doc is still the primary person
that is connected
to the patient.
Specialty mental health may or
may not be available, but
we now increasingly have
these care managers.
And if we can put something in
the center there that can manage
communications between
those that can monitor and
help monitor the patient that
can provide support and can.
We may be able to get something
would actually sustainable
and workable.
I'm gonna skip through this.
This is sort of the,
this is the summary, but
in interest of time, I wanna get
to some of the sensing stuff.
Cuz I wanted to talk with some
of the people here about that.
And just briefly, you can think
about these digital mental
health tools particularly
the skills based ones as little
feedback devices, right?
So they get information in,
they process it, and
they provide that information
back to the user in some way,
that's hopefully useful to them.
Provide some insight,
some motivation, right?
And the problem that a lot of
users encounter is putting
the information in, right?
We've all probably
downloaded apps that we
think is gonna be great.
And then we use them for
a few days and
get sick in the information and
uninstall it, right?
So that's where potentially
having some way of acquiring
those data like in the same way
we can get step counters now.
Have made a big impact on people
who wanna be physically active,
it maybe helpful.
So, just a little bit of
the work that we've done.
When we started a few years ago,
we developed an app,
Purple Robot.
They can pull the sensor data
off of Android phones, and
this is our first.
Mostly, we did this to try
to debug the software, but
we enrolled about 30 people, and
there was a pretty good
range of depression.
And so,
this is two weeks of data, and
these are some clusters
from GPS that we got.
So, I need some features
from GPS features.
And so you see here,
location variance,
the the variety of
places a person goes was
pretty strongly related to
their level of depression.
So, people who tend to go to the
same place all the time are more
likely to be depressed.
But novelty, people are less
Entropy, if you spend more time,
if your time is distributed
across places more evenly,
you're less likely
to be depressed.
If you tend to spend most of
your time at home or at work,
like it says home-stay there,
you're more likely
to be depressed.
And the one that I was
particularly interested in here
was circadian movement.
So this is people who tend to be
more rhythmic in their movement
through geographic space.
They were less likely
to be depressed.
So it seem a mood
would pull people off.
So this was interesting, so we
thought, Could be just chance.
So we got another dataset
from Andrew Campbell,
who had collected
a student life dataset, and
run the same analysis.
So these were,
about 50 students who they got
their PHQ9 measure of depression
at the beginning of the semester
at the end of ten weeks.
And then collected their GPS
data over this ten weeks.
Now you see here
is the baseline,
the number of places
that they went.
Location variance and circadian
movement were significant.
Not as high as in
the first sample, but
they still remained significant.
And at the end, there was
a pretty broad correlation.
A lot of different
GPSHs related.
So the general idea that
movement through space was
related to depression
seems to be confirmed. Yeah.
>> Sorry, what was this,
what happened between the what
did you have the people?
>> They went to school.
These were students at the
beginning of their quarter and
at the end of the quarter.
>> Okay.
>> We have haven't do anything,
or Andrew didn't have
them do anything.
>> All right.
>> Just a regular life.
So we looked at, so one of
the things, I don't have a slide
on this, one of the things that
I wondered if this is really
true then probably we would see
stronger effect on weekends.
Because during the week,
their movement is less
under their own control.
They have to go to class,
they have to do this or that.
On the weekends, they're
free and indeed we saw for
a number of these features they
were stronger on the weekends.
Another thing we looked at was
If at the baseline depression,
does that predict movement?
So if you know how depressed I
am today, does that tell you
anything about how I'm gonna
move through geographic space
next week, five weeks from now,
ten weeks from now?
You know, it's largely
what we would've expected.
So, at the same measurements
taken at the same time there was
sort of a modest correlation,
and
that all went towards
zero as time went on.
And then we look at
it the other way.
So the GPS feature is predicting
depression 10 weeks later and
what, we were surprised to see,
I was actually was surprised
that there is no change.
So, how people move through
geographic space tells you just
as much about how
depressed I am today as it
does about how depressed I'm
going to be in 10 weeks.
And another slide I don't have,
I should have had,
is the amount of
change in depression.
And these people went up and
down, so
there's a lot of
movement in this sample.
And they're not,
they're students.
They're not necessarily
all mentally doing fine.
So, what this suggest here
is that how we move through
geographic space may be
an early warning detector for
depression before people
start having symptoms,
one of the things we might
see is social withdrawal or
changes in patterns of movement.
At the same time we published
our first article, fortunately
Micro Mucolesi was doing
the same thing at UCL in London.
And found similar features,
we were fortunately, for
one time in my life I actually
didn't get scooped and
we got published
a month before he did.
There's another group in Oxford,
that did the same kinda thing.
These are actually using our
features and they did it with
bipolar patients and
they can predict depression.
So this is, yeah this is looking
good so we got our first study,
then we replicated it,
now got independent people.
So we did another study that we,
where we got 211 people from
around the country, and
different people we collected
this over the space.
They were enrolled
in six weeks and
we got their depression
at the beginning and
the end and tracked a bunch
of different stuff and
it got nothing, it was really.
So we thought maybe this
was done over the winter.
Maybe it's going outdoors
in Minneapolis in
December is different
than Miami.
Maybe we had a broader range
of people older people move
differently than younger people.
We looked at a lot of the look
like younger people we've got
an effect.
But a lot of these we
just got no significance.
And you know, it is,
was very disappointing but yeah?
>> So, don't you have a baseline
or control for these people so
that they can compare you
know whether people have
been [INAUDIBLE] in the Winter,
compared to these people.
So that you have some sort of
baseline as opposed to non
oppressed people because you
know warm rather than cold.
>> Well we did have, we didSo I
should say that this group was
roughly divided into quarters.
So one quarter had high
depression and high anxiety,
one had high depression and
no anxiety,
one had high anxiety and
no depression and
one quarter that when
a healthy controls.
>> Okay so when you compare
it against the baseline of
the healthy versus how much
more or less [INAUDIBLE]
>> We just couldn't
see anything.
>> Couldn't see anything.
>> I think, I don't think
>> Coasts versus the midwest?
>> We did not, we looked at, I
mean there's probably ways that
we can do this to try to
look at this more carefully.
There's a lot of issues in here.
I don't necessarily believe
this is the final story but
I think what this does,
the message I think that I'm
getting this is that this is
a much more complicated issue
than we thought initially.
So, the other studies are small,
they tend to be geographically
defined in a small area
a narrow scope of people.
And I'll talk about this in a
moment, we'll talk about it now.
I think what we're dealing
with is an enormous amount of
variability that
you have to manage,
that you've got differences in
how people use their phones.
In weather, in, you know,
health, in age, and, I mean just
a huge amount of variability
that, you know, any small study.
I mean, all these studies
are 10, or 30 people,
and mostly done with students,
you know, the, and CS students,
probably not general students,
you know.
So the, when you move this out
and a lot of the studies also, I
think that part of that is that
in CS, you, to get published you
have to do something that
nobody's done before.
And so it's not replicability,
that's not highly prized.
But in public health,
we have to have things
that you can replicate.
And so, I think there's a lot
of room that where we can
work together in this but
it's not gonna be simple.
So I think we're
almost out of time, so
I'm just gonna kind of wrap up
and what we're doing here is,
what we're doing now is we just
got another grant funded to
extend this and we're
started to extend this work.
And we're partnering
also now with UCLA so
UCLA has a large project
that they're starting called
the Depression Grand Challenge.
So they are, their goal is
to enroll 100,000 people and
track them over 10 to 15
years with everything,
genetics All kinds
of stuff cuz they
wanna solve the problem of
depression that's the goal.
And this is kind of the highest
level of the university
that they made this initiative.
And so we're working with them
to try to start doing this kind
of sensing to get this sensing.
So the next year or two, they're
planning on enrolling around
10,000 people, and we're
trying to get this, get for
at least a large segment
of those people,
good software on their phones
where we can pull the data off.
So that's kind of
the direction we're going in.
And I think to solve
these kinds of problem,
that's what we're
going to need to do.
You can also say that what we
did get out of this are things
like we could in this sample.
We could see when people woke up
and when they went to bed within
a ten minute window and we could
get that within 90% accuracy.
We could get the relationship
to their contacts.
Was it a Friend, a family
member, because how you text and
phone is different in those
different categories.
So, we can predict that.
There are things that we can
predict more reliably and
I think those are going to be
behaviors that are more proximal
to the phone sensors.
If there's a direct line from
the sensor to the behavior, It
is probably going to be easier
or more reliably detectable.
You get things like depression,
which is vague and
expressed very
differently across people,
it is going to be a lot harder
to get reliable detection.
I'm going to end it here,
just say thank you to
a lot of people cuz this
wasn't just my work this
is a lot of people.
So, thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> It makes you feel better,
In fact they found closeness
to home and closeness to work.
That the two most highly
predictive features in machine
learning model.
For how to press [INAUDIBLE].
And it went both ways,
if you loved work, then it was
a super-good predictor of
you not being depressed.
You hated your job [LAUGH], so
we saw some location
based information, too.
>> Yeah I think there's
something there, And
it's interesting because I don't
think we've ever been able
to really track it
that well before.
So I sort of started looking at,
some geographers have used this.
There's a guy in Israel,
I'm trying to remember his name.
Noam, I can't think of it.
Anyway, so
he's been funded by the various,
the Israeli Tourist Board and
the Italian Tourist Board to use
for sensing for
all kinds of things.
But he's interested in mood.
And so he had this great study
in Jerusalem where they got
5,000 tourists and they were
collecting their GPS data.
They, I think they got
some kind of GSR sensor,
like a wrist-worn sensor and
then they got their mood, and
he created the mood
map of Jerusalem.
And it's like, you can see
elevations that are reflected
across all of these as people
get closer to the Wailing Wall,
and it's just really amazing
how like the geography of that
city can impact people's moods.
So I think there's a lot
that we can learn.
People's rhythms
are reflected in it.
Other questions or
comments or critiques?
>> So when you say about
the connecting sensitive data
on the phones, is that
specifically about location?
But going forward,
do you have other data?
>> We've collected-
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> What we collected in
that last study,
it wasn't just GPS.
Certainly call is lot used on
Android, so we have call and
text logs.
Light, So like the wake,
the sleep wake,
time was a big factor.
You can get a lot just knowing
when people go to bed the first
time cuz people
are fairly consistent.
But like also sound,
light was a factor,
use of the phone.
So we had a bunch of them.
We did not get accelerometry cuz
that just burns up the battery.
And we're trying other little
things like maybe if we can turn
all the sensors on for
like 30 seconds periodically
during the day, that will
give us a sort of a burst of
data that would be useful.
I don't know, but
those are the kinds of things
that might be helpful to talk
with you about cuz you're
thinking about these things.
>> All right, no more questions?
Let's give another
round of applause.
>> [APPLAUSE]